one of the challenges of these new
technologies is not just that we're
living in denial over what's going on
but that we're often sort of overwhelmed
by them and one of the groups that I met
with for the book where people at the
Red Cross and then another one was at
Human Rights Watch there was an
interesting thing that someone at the
International Red Cross said to me about
this where I said you know what there's
so much bad going on in the world right
now how can we waste time on thinking
about the laws that surround these new
things like unmanned systems and
robotics and it's completely valid
answer there is a ton of bad things
going on in the world but for me what's
interesting is you could have said the
exact same thing in 1939 or 1944 there's
so much bad going on in the world why
should we waste time trying to figure
out what's going on with this new thing
called atomic bombs that's just you know
fantasy that's just science fiction and
so the result is we weren't ready for it
there's a broader question of the
ethical issues that surround these
systems is does it make war crimes more
or less likely that is some people think
you can put morality into these machines
you can put ethical codes into them sort
of equivalent to like isaac asimov's
three laws and so you could have as one
scientist put it more ethical killing
devices and that they would follow rules
that maybe soldiers wouldn't so for
example a lot of war crimes happen when
a soldier's buddy is killed and rage
takes over and they lash out against
local civilians robots don't have
emotion so you wouldn't have that happen
they can also be a lot more
discriminating they soldier has to burst
into a room in a microsecond figure out
who's the threat or not and shooter
shoot and sometimes they make mistakes a
robot can go into the room take his time
figure out who's a threat and you don't
have to worry about the person dining
behind them that's true but machines
can't be moral by the very definition of
morality they don't have empathy they
don't have a sense of guilt so to a
machine
80 year old grandmother in a wheelchair
is just the same as a t-80 tank except
for a couple ones and zeros that are
different in the programming language
and that's got to be disturbing to us in
a certain way